.
SOS SUPPORTERS
ARLEUT
COELESIC
LOT LIKE THEPR AS ON HIM.S SARA
JOHNSON TOYSH RUING FOR A
IR, IT SEEMS THERE IE WISCONSIAD
MISINFORMATION O THERE ARE PEM
TI
IT A PROBLEME ASSUME THEY BELIE
>> Reporter: DG TH
IMS
ORG THE FBI HA
INSURRECTION BUT DT IT.
Y
FACTS AND SPREADONIES
HAS  SHE STATE
WONDERING WHAT HAPPENED TO RON
JOHNSON.
>> HE WAS OUR Y.
>>HEE
T OWN COUNTY GOP WENRALLYISON A
DEVOID OF REALITY. DONALD TRUMPO
LICANS LING UNFND CLAECKERHNSON
ELECTION FRAUD.
>> I SAID, RONURPRISIN CAL
THEC. SAID,EST
1.5 MIIO
DONALD TRUMP.
I'M NOT STUPID.
>> I GOING TSE
.
H HT ALL
YOU THAT COLUMN?
>> I SURE DI
AH I GOT A TEXT ON JANUARY 7thT
INSURRECTION.
MARK, IT IMY SINCERE
NEVER HAVE TPEO A FE WEASEL SUC.
PL TT
SOLL UP
GLAS TOR OF THE HA
CO
EC
INTERVIEW.
HS NSON EXPEEDALL TO
LATER HE WENT PUBLIC WIT CLAIMS
ABOUANADYONE WHO WOULD DO THAT
NOTHING,
SAY SHOULD BE GIVEN
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Reporter: IN A STATEMENT
JOHNSON SAYS THOSE REMARKS ARE
CONS WITH WHAT I'VE BEEN PUBLICO
INTERVIEWS W HWON.
OF ELECTION ONTINUED TO RAISE
TO MICHELLNS
GUY SHE FIRST BROUGHT TO
PARTY T
HE DOESN SKIRT AROUN
HE IS NOT LOOKINTOE ILY ALL THE
TIME.
>> Reporter: S WON
ERA PERSONAL'S HEART
CTIS CONCERNABT
LTHCARN SPOULD
HEARD A PIN DROP.
>> Reporter: BUT SAS
SHE WANTED TOALNG
IN DAYENM POLITICS, BUI'M LI COD
>> Reporte BUT SHE HELPEHIM
MAN S WITHIV
AND RADIO TAL
COUPLED WITH HOUNTING
BACKGROUND.D IN A
GOP WAVE ELECTION.
>> WE NEED TO RESTORE FISCAL
SANITY TO THISIOeporteN FINEGO
AND JOHND R
VICTOR
THIS TIDE DONALD
P.♪ATARE,KE, WHATD?
>> WELL, IWOQUESTIONS.
ONE IST
TIKE,
WHY IS HYING AND DOING ALL
RAIG GILBERT
G POLI SLLOWING JOHNSON
SINCE HE WAS ELECTED
>> ITHNSON BERENATE FROM
IT NLEN POLITICS
TO BE E
ON SOME OF ISSUES.
>> Reporter: THOSES
INCLUDE QUTISAFE AFE.
THE FD, DANGS.T'T . HEALTH OFFIR
SAID HE WANTS THPAO D HOPES THE
KEY ROLE ININ
IS ALSO AN
EARLY ADVOCATE FOR COVID EAEN
HE WANTS ALL THE DRUGS
RESECHSEE HIM
AS A POWER-HGR
TRYIO  A GRIP ON THE
REMAINS EAGER TO QUESTION THE
ESTABLISHMENT.
>> RONS
T
T'T IT THAT WAY WITH T
VAS NO
BEING A .ST RONO LISTEN
SIDESGS.
>> Reporter: G
BRIAN SHIMMING JOHNSON'SS AP
TRACK ON HISE'S A LOT OFS SAY TO
PLGEO TERMS.
E CAPITOL or BLACK
RIOTERS ART. PEOPLWHO TRULY RES
ENFORCEMENUL
K A LAW.
HAD THE TA BEERNPR
ELECTION, AND THOSE WERE TENS OF
THOUSAOF BLACK LIVES MATTE
ANTIFACONCERNED.
>> Reporter: JOHNSON'S OKESWOMA
THOSE WHO D LEGALLY.
>>S A PERSHO MORPH
THST PART OUT LOUD.ING REAL RNK.
WITH CANDIDATES
LIKE MANDEY ING JOHNSON'S WORDSS
>> Reporte R .IS
OFFICE SHE  TO DECIDE IF HE IS O
THNOFOR A THTERM.
FOONOMLRSING JOHNSON R RE-ELECT